Joey why are you so sad Joey being 77 in
human has so yet to find a spouse now
this could be for many reasons but maybe
he's batting for their Antibes therefore
I made him a sheep's uniform let's see
if this works a drought of yet
gonna be a sheep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
why do I always come up with the most
difficult movies to shoot each idea just
seems to get more and more knotty I came
to South Africa to have a break but I
literally just can't stop making movies
thank you so much story blocks for
helping me make this one I use a lot of
stocks to tell my stories as it makes an
app bit more compelling and visual
instability inclusivity inclusivity this
is really something that I'm trying to
nail I want to collaborate more but not
only with bigger youtubers to grow but
also with the legend you watching this
phone and the best way to do this for
now is Twitter Karen pussycat we can
also send me a challenge I can compete
in 24 hours no restrictions now we wait
1,000 people put forward to the ideas
some of them were just and then I found
this one a kid called Adrienne asked me
to find him a girlfriend which is this a
pretty outrageous but relatable I'll
tell you wanna sake so I replied and
said send me your address make sure
you're available and pack a bag in case
we need to go anyway and then he replied
pretty quickly I chose this idea because
well time for a story this story is
called playing pool with a room well
because I didn't score that often why I
guess I feared rejection so much that I
hardly even tried I would resort to lame
pickup lines on chat rooms and not even
know if the person on the other hand was
an oven or a pretty blonde like in the
picture until I eventually gained the
confidence to speak to girls at school
which led me to being ban the friend Oh
Dan I love you but not like that
friend-zoned this thing turned into me
becoming a bit of an arse towards girls
because i thought that the girls
wouldn't friendzone me in this also
didn't work but then at the end of the
story I made gabs who I'm about to marry
and so I guess I must have done
something right and this idea is to
figure out what exactly that was the
plan
just like we're making a movie let's
look at location first this cape town
the right place to find a companion the
best person to call is my friend hi you
bro beans I'm making a film about
finding a girlfriend in Cape Town but
obviously not for me why not go to
Joburg and here's what I thought is the
best how to find a girl in 2018 or not
attempt and smooth guide by Dan mace
booked two tickets to Joburg download
every dating have known to man ride to
ride pickup blurb in the bio print out
pictures of Hadrian time to surprise him
okay go around the circle
[Music]
oh great that's not my mom things are
gonna like steal me or something no
don't worry hi I'm Dan I think it says
favorite you're probably this is before
where that's cool it's really big see
nice I'm a wingman firstly the spray of
Cologne one on the neck parity two beers
hopes take the edge of another thing you
can mean it a wad of cash
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
screw Joburg epic fail with seriously
deflated egos we booked out of the hotel
and back to game time Oh as long as the
only thing that really helps after an
all-nighter okay last night happened
felt weird
it just didn't feel right so I think
first thing I'm gonna do is delete those
dating apps and then lastly I couldn't
imagine these weird techniques like
printing out flyers and handing them out
to robots and sticking them up on that
y'all agree would ready to put it in
[Music]
I've called over Adrienne to essentially
apologize if we do want to continue with
this film we have about eight hours to
do so and it I'm not this overly
confident guy that can just guard day
and like get all the girls at clubs and
things like that like that's not me like
and maybe we've just gone about it like
completely wrong even like there is this
one girl no really yeah yeah like if I
mentioned there that actually have to
like ah Scott so I just like kept the
scene from a guy feels like there's no
way they're gonna find you have to do it
yeah like that's why I just haven't
bothered you know what do you mean this
is a little glimpse of hope at a
possibility that I'm going to be able to
upload from this Wednesday okay gonna
have to phone it okay I will I will plan
something really I'll send you home now
and then I'll come featuring the plan
first is to find the correct location
right next to the ocean with mountain
and sunset views then to get supplies
and not make it too romantic and this is
done with pizza then to set up and
finally Fitch Adrienne looking fly lucky
fly as soon as you walk down into Beach
you just walk on the path and you'll
know exactly what's going on it should
be a dead I'm filming this thing
I mean slightly okay I'll probably end
up leaving before you Dan yeah I'll call
you later and if everything goes good
I'll tell you about it and you can play
this to Emily and see if she's happy
[Music]
am I ever gonna phone him later and find
out how things went yeah 300 ago
what has chilled me okay
important note I was given the rights
but everyone foamed in this movie I
removed all the scenes that each person
in the film was not comfortable with I'm
truly happy everything went well for
Adrian and now I have a new friend yay
I hope you're next as I said right in
the beginning of the film this was a
sponsored video sponsored by my friends
at story blocks but once again before
you go ah it's a sponsored video now
you've ruined the whole video by saying
this at the end
that's ridiculous story bugs made this
film happen and thank you to them and if
you watching in my films you know that I
use tons of stocks I use story block
stocks therefore for me this was a
really easy integration and if you'd
only hear about me talk about all the
benefits you can go directly to the link
in the description or type in story
blocks video.com slash Dan mace to check
it out right now being a youtuber that's
come from a directing background quality
imagery is how I tell my stories it's
how I take a script and bring it to life
essentially that's what a filmmaker is
but because I'm uploading weekly I
generally don't have the time to go out
and shoot absolutely everything and
because most of my Cod zips are so broad
I like to use a lot of stock footage and
for me that's really where the story
blocks is just super beneficial here's
some stuff sides can come in and pardon
expense story blocks is a lot more
affordable basically to me it just
removes the restriction of my
imagination I can really just think as
far and wide as I want and know that
I'll be able to find a clip that will
match that if you head over to their
member library you can download all the
stock you can imagine in HD
and in 4k as well as After Effects
templates version backgrounds and more
let's get exclusive discounts on
millions of additional marketplace clips
we say 40% on every purchase compared to
non-members and the original artist
takes home a commission of the sale
price all the content is royalty-free so
you can use it for commercial or
personal projects such as YouTube videos
like I do best part is this new clips
added all the time so there's always
something fresh as always don't forget
I'll see you next week Wednesday and
your awesome
[Music]
now Copernicus has had to learn at this
he figured sold orbital does return of
his he could see a little more than four
Ptolemy but he still could not defeat
his own jealousy Pablo Picasso never got
called an [ __ ] but he still had a
date night
[Music]